some families of victims of online abuse
were at the hearing and meta CEO Mark
zukerberg was forced to face them would
you like to apologize for what you've
done to these good
people I I'm sorry everything that you
have all gone through the apology muted
as it was was made earlier each of the
tech CEOs expressed concern for what
they termed abuse of their platforms but
insisted they took stringent measures to
prevent harm to Young users we make it
very difficult for predators to find
teens on Snapchat direct messaging is
not available to any users under the age
of 16 I know you don't mean it to be so
but you have blood on your hands you
have a
product you have a
product that's killing people members
brought specific instances of online
abuse including the sale of drugs
Bridget lost her teenage son
after he took a fentanyl lace pill that
he purchased on the internet a tragedy
shared by Sam Chapman who son Samy was
found dead at the age of 16 having taken
fentanyl that was sold on the snap
platform uh dealer reached out on
Snapchat to Sammy with a colorful drug
menu offered him something for free in
order to addict him and delivered a
counterfeit drug to our home like a
pizza with a lethal dose of fentanyl in
it Sam Chapman had a meeting with a snap
CEO even Spiegel who only attended this
hearing after being
subed and I asked him to put on
third-party safety software and he said
that data privacy meant that they
couldn't do it during the hearing
Spiegel apologized to parents whose kids
overdosed after buying drugs on the snap
platform section 230 of the
communications act says platforms cannot
be held liable for what is posted by
users therefore there is no legal
accountability for any harm that may be
a consequence there's not one law in the
book cuz you oppose everything we do and
you can't be sued the demand by
committee members and by The Grieving
parents like Sam Chapman there must be
accountability Mike Hannah Al jaer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer